this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you thanks for coming appreciate
the opportunity to talk to you today
what I've learned working in apples is
that it just it draws a certain level of
fanaticism and that can be a good thing
and that can be a bad thing and I'm
probably an apple fanatic as well this
is I want you to pay attention to this
slide this is a postcard from Sweden and
it makes a nice artwork but I'll show
you later what I mean by being a fanatic
this was also an opportunity where an
artist came to see our Apple collection
she had seen the botany of desire she
fell in love with her apple trees and
she brought three artists from LA to
take pictures of our apples in the
winter
it's a muslin sheep it's about 20 by 30
and you put it up in the middle of the
orchard in winter and it acts like a
giant sail and only the phd was behind
the sail trying to keep it in line and
then I went wait a minute these guys are
too smart to try to keep that from
blowing away this they use nails to
stick all the apples in I thought when
they made that get that post part so you
can see the extent that's probably you
know 30 by 40 feet they place each Apple
in between the nails rather than just
stick it on a nail so that they can use
the apples after now that's crazy
okay so another Apple fanatic that
resulted in a lot of the apples that you
know today was Johnny Appleseed Johnny
Appleseed was a real person went by the
name of John Chapman he thought it was
morally bad to graft apple trees and
I'll talk about grafting a little bit
later that you should only spread seed
but he was a really savvy businessman
and he collected seed from cider ease
and he went all over the eastern US and
gave out seed in exchange for people
listening to him about his religion he
died a very wealthy man
but Disney loved the story and so
there's more books on Johnny Appleseed
that you can even shake a stick at but
he was responsible by spreading these
seeds because apples were not native to
the US we only had small crab apples and
a lot of the colonists apples weren't
adapted by spreading these seeds they
inter mated and were selected for hearty
material and that became the evolution
of apples like Rome Beauty and others ok
so Nigel talked about the challenges one
of the challenges is we can't even agree
on a scientific name the u.s. goes by
Malus domestica Europe largely goes by
malice pumila and people from Germany
argue that it should be Silvestri's and
so Apple is an ancient a leap a leap
Lloyd that behaves like a diploid but
there's also triploids tetraploid atha
mix we have gametophyte akin
compatibility and what that ensures is
that Apple is out crossing so you clamp
can't plant one apple tree you have to
plant two to allow for pollen spread and
when I took plant breeding courses I
always heard about imbrie ting a trade
of interest well an apple there's
inbreeding depression so you can't breed
back and retain the cultivar so every
cross I make are new hybrids and it's
clonally propagated so the origin of
Apple is in the Kazakhstan China region
and it's been of scientific interest to
get germ plasm from the center of origin
that might have genes of interest and
there's been a lot of exploration by
Cornell scientists to go to these areas
and collect apples and their exploits
are covered by Cornell because I guess
the the native monkey populations
figured if they collected the apples the
monkeys wanted to steal the bags of
apples and so they had to beat off the
hordes of monkeys the other reason that
the Kazakh forests
became of interest as how many people
here have read Michael Pollan's botany
of desire okay if one more person calls
us and says I want to walk through the
Kazakh forests and it was wonderful
because it got people interested he
talked about the genetic diversity in
this these seedling populations of
Kazakh apples but I think the people
that read it seem to think that we had
nothing else to do but take people
through these forests then the diversity
is tremendous but I hope to show you
today that the diversity in our
populations is equally impressive
because Apple is very heterozygous and
has a lot of genes that lend itself to
diversity so most of you have seen
different apples but the germ plasm
collection at the USDA houses two to
three thousand different apple
accessions including those from the
origin of the species the curator is dr.
Zhang igano and young and the curator is
Thomas Chow and they are very active and
expanding the collection but also doing
very valid phenotyping and genotyping
they're looking at snip markers and
they're also looking at genome-wide
Association studies and what's great
about that collection is I get to use it
and don't have to pay for its
maintenance now Nigel made me feel old
because I usually tell people don't tell
when I graduated from college that's
past history but I did go back to an
Apple gene list that when I came and
took over the job this was the status in
1963 of the Apple genes that we know
about all of ten and even there they
weren't really all documented and what I
hope to show you today is that we've
made remarkable progress but the sad
part is about five of these still remain
not quite investigated
the first linkage map was developed at
Cornell by a hybrid of crabapple white
angel by Rome beauty and again I'll show
my age the Apple map was largely
isozymes and rapid markers and the
coverage was pretty slim but we were
thrilled and next in 2010 we have the
Apple genome published and obviously it
comes from the efforts of a lot of
people but this really broke through
things for us so we were able to have
the genome sequence of Golden Delicious
and that is now available for us to look
at in terms of looking at markers or
genes of interest I'm also a member of
the Rose breed one of those large
multi-state projects and I was talking
to someone and I said but there's three
Apple breeders in the US and somebody
said well gee for security of our
national food supply should you all be
in the room at the same time and if you
go to Japan or China or other places
there's tons of Apple breeders but here
there used to be probably an apple
breeder in every state kate is at
Washington I'm at Cornell and Jim Looby
is in Minnesota we also have a big
roseburg Advisory Committee what we want
to do is use the collections that all of
us have as well as the breeding
populations to come together and share
data on phenotyping and genotyping we
found out very quickly that a lot of our
parents were not what they should be
Honey Crisp was a surprise because not
only was the pollen parent what it
wasn't supposed to be but the seed
parent wasn't whether it was supposed to
be and it's hard to goof up the seed
parent so we're using this and we came
together and we realized that we wanted
to emphasize quality and we know that
the most important traits for consumers
are Christmas
but texture flavor however maintenance
of this quality through time is really
essential and markers have been
developed and are being tested across
populations okay I'm gonna give you a
really fast fax on the Apple breeding
program but if you're at Cornell and on
Ithaca you should know that we are one
of the oldest programs we're one of the
largest in the world we've named 66
varieties and we very much integrate
genetics genomics and breeding we're a
multidisciplinary we benefit very
greatly from the expertise found in
Ithaca and Geneva and Cornell
Cooperative Extension plays a vital role
in putting out a lot of our materials in
grower trials collecting data and
getting the grower feedback on some of
this material okay so we make controlled
hybrids we do do trans gene technology
but a lot of times and especially within
two weeks unlike last year where we got
frozen out we should have apple blossoms
apple blossom as his popcorn stage we
don't want bees to visit the flower so
we select one parent as a seed parent
and the other parent we choose to get
pollen from and I got briefed my husband
and I were dating and I was out in the
field doing this process which is called
emasculation and he said you look tired
and I said yeah I've been emasculating
all day and he said you really shouldn't
say that in public so he's gotten used
to it he still won't volunteer to help
but so we removed the we removed the
pedals and the anthers again so bees
won't visit and it guarantees that when
you buy an apple in the grocery store
the seeds could be hybrids with crab
apples or any other variety when I make
a cross I'm controlling both the mother
and the father so every seed within that
apple our sisters I don't know why we
don't say brothers but they're all
sisters and I complained thousands of
these apples
and they maintain the genetic
characteristics of the mother combined
with the father and our goal is to
produce better varieties than what we
currently have but then the beauty of it
is once I find something that I like so
the seeds are planted there on seedling
roots and it used to be it took forever
8 to 12 years from planting a seed to
getting fruit we can get fruit in the
fourth Leafs of four years after
planting and in fact one of the
selections that we named was twelve
years from making the cross to
commercialization now those of you that
work with tomato and Arab adopts us are
saying twelve years but it used to be 40
so what we feel like we're rocket
science so you see a selection that you
like and then you take a bud stick and
as many bugs are on that stick
I can make exact clones of that
selection and so every Fuji apple
derives back from the original Fuji
clone in Japan Macintosh etc so I take a
bud I put it on a root stock that's been
bred by Gennaro Fazio to dwarf the tree
bring an into production sooner we allow
that bud to take and then the top of the
root stock is cut off the bud becomes
the tree and so anytime you see a tree
in somebody's yard or in an orchard you
see the swelling and that's the joint
union of the Scion the fruiting work and
the root stock and while I always loved
about Sciences I love what I do and I
get to work on stuff that I get to eat
all the time
Gennaro fatsia loves what he does and he
works with roots I don't quite get that
ok Cornell varieties we're very well
known for Cortland Portland was released
in 1915 it's going to be an antique in
two years so it's gonna have a hundred
year anniversary it's still a popular
variety McGowan in 1923
so if you come from Cornell or DTI you
don't call it McCune it's McGowan named
breeder in Canada and Empire 1968 and
Jonagold
1966 how many of you have had jhana
Ville
hey good good crowd so really good Apple
rated by a lot as a top desert variety
but it became more popular in Belgium
than it did here okay so we had a good
track record but what we were pleased
about is we were asked to give out
apples at Capitol Hill and I was
competing giving out apples against free
champagne wine hors d'oeuvres oysters
and we were like this is gonna be a long
night and some of the staffers whose
favorite Apple in New York was Granny
Smith which does not ripen within our
climate tried some of our apples and
started yelling get out of here and so
we knew we had some apples that were
going to be popular if we could get
enough growers to try them but our
industry is a little complicated we have
six hundred and seventy four apple
growers we're second in the nation and
production a distant second from
Washington but we've had a program well
before they did McIntosh is still our
number one variety and what was
interesting is have some of you heard
about sweet Tango it's a club variety so
the breeder in Minnesota made this
variety one person in Minnesota got
rights to it and everybody else was shut
out some people the New York State were
able to grow it and brothers on to farms
next door one would have it in one
wouldn't and what we didn't want to do
is come up with an exclusive variety and
shut out our growers and I needed money
for the program so we thought can we do
a plan where New York growers will have
exclusive rights to two of these new
varieties and give the industry and
advantage and give us some needed income
so we decided that because there were
674 growers we had to have an
organization that did not exist before
to move them forward we needed the
growers to buy in and plant sufficient
volume to get
market empire when it first came out
somebody might grow five trees ten trees
an acre of trees and then the grocery
store would say there's not enough
volume and so you're between a rock and
a hard place if you don't have enough
volume you can't sell it to the grocery
stores the grocery stores don't say okay
if you get enough volume will buy it so
we knew we need to get the industry to
commit to planting enough to give
400,000 boxes so that there was enough
volume for marketing but we also needed
dollars for marketing and promotion
because that sells a variety so a year
or two ago we formed the New York apple
growers came up with the New York apple
growers limited liability corporation
and we're equal partners in the
commercialization of these two varieties
we share equally and risks and rewards
royalties are split between the
corporation and myself myself on my
program and also we started something
where normally we get a royalty per tree
now with these varieties we get a
royalty per tree and a royalty per box
of fruit sold and as an apple breeder to
be able to say that we've gotten a
commitment to plant nine hundred acres
of these two varieties is pretty amazing
and it's going to be with an over the
next two years and about sixty percent
will be something for New York one and
forty percent will be New York to that
or not those will not be their names the
names will be announced soon we just
need it to hold it with patenting
there's marketing plans underway it'll
be in stores in 2014 but I think that
will be at Cornell orchards this fall
and the reaction has been very good so
New York one Honey Crisp fans here okay
if you like Honey Crisp you're gonna
like New York one
it has Honey Crisp as one parent but is
more attractive I'll let Chris Watkins
argue of the production Channel
that we might have but I would beg to
say that we have a lot less problems
than the Honeycrisp parent it's got high
sugar and has done well New York -
appeals to people that like a little bit
more sugar acid balance it also is very
low browning and it it's nice that these
two varieties are different and it
appeal to different consumers but the
beauty of having something like this
this not only was the industry behind it
but Chris Watkins Jackie and Frannie
arranged opportunities for growers to
try these apples under different storage
regimes and not know what those storage
regimes were and comment on the quality
and these are all commercial growers and
the beauty of it is these guys all have
their own businesses so my AG is on top
of what they do to make a living every
day and so here's an example of the
post-harvest assessment where we're
ranking what the quality was at
different times hoping to draw what the
best storage temperature would be and
also the atmosphere at which it's stored
and then we also got Deb Perot CEO and
the Dyson school to have students come
up with names for these apples some of
them were great some of them were awful
but the students really got into it and
it was a nice opportunity I'm going to
switch a little bit because I recognize
that not very many of you are going to
go into apples as a career not when you
can work on a rabbit OPS's but I'll hope
to bring in some ideas and maybe have
you think of apples in a little bit
different way so what if you come out of
this and you end up in a new position
and you're working on a new crop or a
crop that you really are not familiar
with what do you know about that plant
that you will be investigating
I'm not trying to be preachy but we all
learn that even when you've been in a
position a long time it's surprising how
much you can learn that isn't known or
may not be in the literature
so understanding variation is huge so if
you find yourself researching anything
new understanding the range of materials
that have is available is crucial
because a lot of studies are done on
common cultivars but there is such a
range for whatever characteristic that
you're looking at but more importantly
is how to phenotype properly at the
right stage if you're doing gene
expression studies or any study getting
the plants at the right stage and
minimizing the variation that's inherent
in every crop but especially apples is
important and in all grants there's a
lot of money for genotyping but we're
recognizing that there's a phenotyping
bottleneck and so your your markers and
your genetic discoveries are only as
good on the material and the phenotyping
that it's based in it's like computers
garbage in garbage out and unfortunately
this view is still very much minimized
or ignored
so give an example an apple that a lot
of researchers had not been aware of
some of the visiting scientists there's
five usually five flowers per cluster
and this is the dominant the king
dominant apple so that what what that
means is it's kind of a evolutionary
perspective the first apple is wonderful
quality but if you get frozen out then
those laterals will still give you a
crumb so it allows Apple to set under
adverse conditions however if you're
doing physiology studies or gene
expression studies if you're choosing
the king flower that's the best fruit
sometimes
and then you choose in the laterals
you're comparing a little bit apples and
oranges so you're not standardizing it
so you either choose all laterals or
thin it down to a certain number or
choose only Kings and then some
varieties are very much king dominant
and others aren't and when you remove
the fruits to study you're stimulating
ethylene production so if you're
studying ethylene response removing
those fruits can be problematic and you
know it sounds kind of common sense but
sometimes researchers have used fruit
from a grocery store without an
understanding of the physiology of
what's going on the other aspect that
you may not know if you say get me some
apples or some kumquats to study is the
crop load you want a balance between
vegetative and and reproductive fruit
and leaves and if that balance isn't
there it's going to greatly affect the
quality of your fruit so this is a case
where the fruit is very much over set
you're going to have reduced level of
quality in those fruits you're going to
have differences in ripening so it's
understanding that balance environmental
effects can you tell me what difference
between those two fruits
like okay so you're right it's the same
variety one is getting a lot of sunlight
the other is that one is probably more
mature but knowing that is really
crucial
it could make a difference between the
Sun and the non Sun side of the fruit in
terms of chemical composition and you
want to have good light exposure when
you're dealing with seedling populations
which I do that can be a challenge
complexity what's the sample size that's
needed if you have that kind of
variation you'll see sometimes sample
size of four well how is that determined
I had four fruits and you know usually
there's good reasons and there's a lot
of great papers in terms of sample size
to have a valid but that needs to really
be taken into effect and then there's
the general variability are you choosing
fruit that's represents the extent of
the crop on the tree are you choosing
the best fruits and all of that's going
to influence the results that you get
develop developmental stage is very
important and we've reached a long
milestone and understanding it better so
Jenson did some est work where he
characterized from the flower stage to
fruit development what was happening
with cell division cell elongation
starch and ripening a recent paper by
Schaefer also looked at changes
depending on when you harvest it if you
harvest it too early you're volatile ZAR
going to be influenced your ethylene is
going to be influenced skin color
changes acidity and starch so
understanding the right stage is crucial
now I'm going to switch a little bit
more because many of you have probably
not seen an apple tree that looks like
this I came back from a visit to a
researcher and I started talking about
this tree and they just kind of shook
their head this is an apple that this
isn't a great picture it should be just
a different one it has usually fruits up
and down like Brussels sprouts and it
a homeotic mutation it's a dominant gene
and it gives us relatively we thought
simple system to study a complex trait
and you can see that I wasn't the only
one that became enamored of it because
we did the first QTL studies using the
kilometer gene in 1997 I think an apple
and now just into 2013 you can see
physical characterization a really nice
study of columnar hormones and find
genetic mapping this by our geneva group
including on by who's in the audience
and so but what's interesting about this
this hormone work we have a columnar
apple and we have the tree so this was a
genetic sport a grower discovered that
one of the branches have a lot of
changed inner nodes he propagated it he
found that it was true to form that it
produced this reduced lateral branching
and when you use it in breeding about
50% of the seedlings can be columnar in
this hormone study he compared the
columnar tree by a non columnar
non-related apple so you had a chance to
look at something that was genetically
similar but analysis was was shifted a
little bit okay so this is where
sometimes there's a breeder you get to
do fun stuff columnar apple dominant
gene weeping apple dominant gene what do
you think happens when I cross the two I
didn't know so we'll make the crust
yep and it helps if you switch with
though the button instead of the clicker
we got trees that were columnar on the
top sub want weeping on the bottom we
also got columnar but you can see this
is what usually happens you get trees
that look like cigarro cactus you have
lateral branches but they're all very
upright you get weeping and our
physiologist said you get trees that
really don't know what they want to do
but this is interesting I've seen a lot
of apple trees I've never seen any that
look like that you want apple trees to
produce to have really straight branches
it brings them into production sooner I
think we got a little carried away there
this is an example where you're having
good segregation of columnar and
standards when you use weeping you can
get this is not a prune tree it's looks
like spokes on a wheel we think it's an
awesome mutation and so again we're
seeing variation that you're not going
to read about until we get closer to
publishing and it may offer chances to
investigate parts of your craft that
we're not possible so I told you that we
use root stocks to dwarf trees but what
if you didn't have to use root stocks so
this is a seedling that is about four
years old
it's sisters are ten feet tall
we have some of these that fruit very
early in the juvenile period this our
two sister seedlings same age same cross
one being dwarf one being standard and
my student who finished recently is and
now is postdoc in with a leg chin use
some of this unique material so this is
a four year old seedling fruiting and
its sisters are probably 20 feet high to
look at GA content with Peter Davies in
biology the other thing that people
don't tell you and I've been beating
about is that sometimes in your studies
if you're doing mapping populations or
you're looking at segregation of traits
there may be lethal that either the
breeder or whoever's looking at the
seedlings may not realize exists
this is pale-green lethal the seedlings
come up they die they don't have good
chlorophyll development they die and if
you don't see them soon enough you just
think you didn't get germination but
it's a heterozygous a lot of plants are
heterozygous for this trait and we are
finding that it's linked to certain
alleles in this case these are three
different plant types in the same
population and these small ones tend to
die a lot of the segregation distortion
we say we think are due to a lot of
these lethal or sub-lethal plants this
is what columnar looks like at a
seedling population you can see they're
reduced in a node length as opposed to
its standard colleagues so I had a
student that came in and he was very
interested in how hybrids coexist so
when you make wide crosses which we can
do an apple how can they coexist and how
do they decide but like the case with
weeping versus columnar which one
survived so we used a columnar parent
because we argued that the columnar gene
should be maintained and we could also
follow it unitive
we used one of the parents of that
hybrid as a control because again I
can't back cross to the same Karen and
we use two different malice species
mallets pasta is one of the native crab
apples and malice de mary i is from
taiwan area and is very low chilling and
not much is known about it and we wanted
to see if we made this cross would we
see columnar would we not and would we
see certain lethality x' or genes being
turned on or turned off and been our
chess keys the student that's looking at
it and he's going to be looking at
methylation activation of transposons
and other attributes a normal seedling
was like the picture I showed you
straight shoot this has world leaves and
has a lot more
internodes in a slight area and it's not
columnar but it's not your standard
apple tree this is an apple tree that
had 21 laterals we don't get laterals
and seedling populations but in these
inner specific populations we're getting
laterals and we think we're going to get
really early fruit production same
population we're seeing perhaps a
kilometer manifestation but dwarf for
some reason and we're seeing very
strange multiple laterals and so this
material air crickets is on a mic skin
Lenara Ben's dissertation committee and
they came out to the field and they said
Susan we didn't think we'd say this but
you almost have too much variation which
can be a good thing but we'll make it
challenging okay red skin color red skin
color should be easy red was supposed to
be dominant to yellow okay so we
developed a marker for red color in
Apple and to tell you the truth I didn't
think I would select out yellow apples
you know there's good quality and both
of them we developed a marker at Cornell
in 1996 but it didn't work for green and
then there's been a lot more Studies on
apples the transgenic studies
overexpressing genes but the problem is
you're gonna have a marker for red
versus yellow but you don't have four
color pattern
it's a striping versus not extent of the
surface colored and the intensity what
was determined in a study is that when
you have striped apples the uncoloured
sectors are actually methylated so
that's the color pattern difference so
this is the kind of variation we see for
apple color this is one population of
one apple from each of different
seedling trees and yes we could have
selected for 50% red this is the color
variation so we have red we have purple
we have orange in this case we would
have selected these two but this whole
cross obviously has some issues again
one seedling from each and then this is
a really interesting attribute where we
have expression of color in the third
layer of epidermis so you usually have
color expression in the first layer in
this case there's color in the third
layer that's showing through and giving
us this broad striping and I'm gonna
condense a lot of it because if anybody
is really interested in all the
intricacies of Apple ID be glad to send
you a PDF I just wanted to show you that
we really are making a lot of progress
like other crops Knibb transcription
factors are responsible for red color
there's an ancient duplication of this
transcription factor and it's
responsible for their red color we have
some apples that you cut them in half
and they look like beets they're so red
inside they're being marketed for
anthocyanin but a lot of them are really
tannic and astringent so if you see that
at the store ask for a sample before you
buy them and then we also are seeing
phenotypic changes they're taking some
of these
they're expressing them and Apple or
other crops and finding out what
phenotypic changes are occurring and in
some cases it's it's really major the
beauty is some of those crosses that I
made with crab apples give to me a
byproduct and that's ornamental types
and so we have some double flower crabs
and we have segregation this is a red
flowered red peddled apple and so it's
nice that I get to study some of the
genetic aspects but also have a
secondary market we are making sure that
those crab apples are resistant to scab
scab is something that we get quite a
bit of time in the orchards in New York
State because Gabe likes rainy seasons
in the spring and what do we have
rainy seasons in the spring we can
screen seedlings at a young stage has
this reaction it's resistant if it has
this reaction it's susceptible but the
beauty is that if the leaf looks like
that the fruit of that tree is going to
have scab for years after what it was
when it fruits so there's good
correlation we've done a lot with apple
scab or Baldwin Cole we develop markers
we look to interactions we found new
sources of resistance we've looked at
transgenic approaches but unfortunately
99% of the material that scab resistant
today relies on one gene for resistance
and so we have to change that and we
will be pyramiding genes for resistance
but it's only good if you have scab
resistance if you have resistance to
powdery mildew for black rot with the
climate change we're seeing new diseases
and disorders that were not problematic
before this is fire blight which we now
have a antibiotic resistant strain in
New York which is going to cause our
growers some issues ok so again I said
it's important to know variation but
it's also important to know if there are
breeders in the crop that you're working
with or people that have spent a lot of
time with the plant they might know of
oddities that will help you understand
and so we keep a lot of stuff which
previous breeders would throw away so
you know citrus can flower and fruit so
can apples not ideal I don't think we're
gonna get to crops out of it but
interesting these the parent of these
two peas are one fruit from each of
seasons the entire progeny look like
that not a homerun I got my PhD in
genetics so I could avoid things like
that sometimes the dice just fall where
they are and we were getting genes for
bad fruit finish again the same idea we
can get not such variation but if all of
them are rusted it's not going to help
you any and this is an apple that every
fruit is chimera so we see that the
fruit color is in sectors like gallo
will do but every single fruit on that
tree is chimeric which could be of
interest fruit size supposedly there's
five genes for fruit size I can't win
the lottery but I can make a cross and
here all five recessive genes in one
crust every seedling in this cross is
small but we think that they're its scab
resistant and it's certainly odd they
taste good and so a grower told me that
he could make a market with the selling
them as apple nuggets we'll see okay
brief glimpse it's of Cornell Research
and I'm gonna make this really brief
because I'm running out of time so I
didn't know Chris Watkins suppose was
going to be here and I did say good
things about him so he's a valued
colleague and cooperator as well as his
cohort there Chris's
and Nigel have done some really whoops
well I'm talking to the slide and don't
have it up there sorry have done some
innovative work at looking at softening
and also storage disorders so when you
see an apple in the store it's perfect
when I first got involved with
post-harvest I was we put him in storage
we took him out and it was ugly and the
post-harvest guys are like wow this is
great
all these diseases and disorders and I'm
because everything's a mess we're making
progress
lo Lang Chang is just known for his work
on sorbitol also looking at metabolism
and as I said this he's looking at the
Sun exposed and the shaded part which is
important and we're lucky to have these
type of people at Cornell at our access
canang Zoo is a tree fruit genomicist
stationed at Geneva he has been looking
with lalang about some of the malic acid
genes and also collaborating with
someone I believe at BTI with aluminum
and also looking at the CEO gene rule
hello and sily are probably known as the
Guru's of antioxidants and I've done
work on the benefits of phytochemicals
and also which compounds are most of
interests because some compounds could
be excreted and not beneficial and so
it's helpful to have them on board we
can find sometimes interesting anomalies
this is New York 673 where those are its
two parents and we found out and
processing them the equipment broke down
that these did not brown or browned a
lot less than their counterparts and so
what this is helpful for is studies of
Apple dippers or fresh cut slices and so
we have quite a project I had a graduate
student Andrea Burke that found a lot of
our advanced selections are better than
what's currently out there and could be
put into Apple dippers and not have to
be treated with ascorbic acid ok other
cornell researchers include chance
robinson who works to convert apple
orchards to really high density and her
bald Winkle who has been key in doing a
lot of the transgenic research so
transgenic apples you can be a proponent
or not but we've learned a lot by using
them we have they add
our understanding about mechanisms of
ripening or genes silenced plants have
added to our role of understanding
ethylene and reduce sorbitol as LaLanne
is looking at and PPO silencing like the
Arctic series is of interest
interestingly the Arctic series which
may be deregulated in the US which were
not from our program the US Apple
industry has decided that they're not
sufficiently in advanced to the
consumers to support the technology they
support the technology but don't feel
it's enough of a change to commercialize
we're gonna have plenty of new hybrids
cornell orchards is gonna have a number
of them for you to try and if you find
something and like it please let me know
if you don't like it tell Nigel I really
want to thank her and former students my
technician kevin maloney my cornell
colleagues funding from a lot of
different sources and we're not breeding
apple trees without leaves but it does
show that we can't produce very
productive apples and a colleague of
mine saw these and it'll be a Christmas
card some year with that I gave you a
nickel tour very fast-paced of Apple
breeding and genetics which hopefully
you came away with a little bit better
understanding or you can go back to the
lab and say thank God I work on Tomatoes
thank you very much
you
it behaves like a diploid but we
actually have we don't have but they've
developed haploid apples which were very
interested it would simplify it even
more
yes a report by Kelly s at the
University of Minnesota and she looked
at Honey Crisp blushed vs. striped
apples and said that the non anthocyanin
portions were methylated and I could
give you that citation
quality yep quality and a a nod to Chris
but it's true being able to store well
and having great shelf life so we've
been criticized because we yes will keep
you at a job a lot of the apples that
you're familiar with like empire
Mackintosh will be at harvest can be 14
to 18 pounds about and could come out of
storage very low we have some apples
that are 22 to 25 pounds it's a whole
different animal we also have some a lot
of people like Honey Crisp which has
good sugar so if you like an apple it
tends to be 30 degrees bricks and as the
bricks increase it tends to increase
your liking we have apples that have 16
18 20 degrees bricks now you can say oh
my god that would be too sweet but we
also can take the malic acid from like
0.2 or 0.4 to 1.1 and it's like eating
shock tarts which I figure if we could
get kids to eat apples instead of those
green apple artificially flavored
candies so much the better
so it's we have some apples that have a
hint of anise you either love them or
you don't a lot of people are like and
then other people think that they're
wonderful so we'll have a lot of
different not your typical apples we're
going to try to get some stickers to see
if Apple's color when the Sun hits them
and I I was the article where we did the
art somehow got translated I showed the
Japanese where they put a sticker on and
it may mean good health and the fruit is
considered a gift and it it's very
carefully reared well a news
organization picked it up and talked
about tattooed apples and they had
pictures of like the most intricate
tattoos but I figured we could do a big
red apple and
you know who knows just by putting the
stickers on but of course I say that and
then a guy was like brides and grooms
would love to have their the date of
their wedding and their names on an
appalam like oh so don't expect that
anytime soon at Cornell arches
we have markers but as I showed you
understanding the phenotypic base and
the genetics that you're working on we
need to test them across populations to
make sure that they're not specific to
the germ plasm in which they've been
developed so we have markers from Alec
acid that we've run on our populations
but we're just verifying it's Okinawa
Jew did that and we also have markers
we're determining qtls for different
sugar attributes but we don't have
markers for a lot of the traits that are
of greatest interest because they're
complex like crunch that's spread all
over we also have markers for allergens
and others so we have a lot of markers
but again it's testing them across a
wide range of materials that's important
and we're getting there
it's a great question and it's I think
it's variety specific there was a great
paper by Gucci on who looked at biennial
bearing and looked at a lot of the
variation but it will depend on all of
those variables but we do know that some
apples are much less variable than
others so there's a strong genetic
component but there's certainly a high
environmental component as well
they don't have qualitative genes for
resistance but they do have very good
field level resistance so for example
Honeycrisp they've just discovered has
several genes for resistance new york
one being a Honeycrisp hybrid might have
such a gene we used it and crosses to to
get a bunch of modifiers but it we may
have incorporated a qualitative gene and
then for things like powdery mildew and
fire blight we have good levels of
resistance so it's not you know it's
certainly going to need sprays but they
perform better than a lot of the
commercial cultivars out there
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu